[Music]
that's what is crazy could be goes to
like walks through walls and stuff so
Leo tech now so much to take over the
world or whatever
for the most part with these villains in
these movies one-and-done never see him
again but it seems like there could be a
possibility for us to see ghosts again
someday I hope so I really hope so um
yeah I mean with the character ghosts
again with the Marvel Universe you
really anything really as possible come
back anyone can come back from the dead
anyone can come back from anywhere so
you can time travel so yes yeah and this
is definitely somebody I think that a
lot of people are going to want to see
again oh yeah no I I really do love her
you know I love her character and you
know I really hope that the audience and
the fans really enjoy her as well
yes we also like the idea that you know
her story wasn't necessarily told by the
end of this movie right you know there's
a there's a last scene with her in the
movie and and it really does sort of ask
the question he makes you think like oh
wow you know she could kind of go either
way at this point what's gonna happen
with this person and we know that Bill
Foster's all in and gonna be with her
but what is their future look like
and now they're suitable off in the
world and we don't know that that was
intriguing yeah yeah so they're I think
you know there's there's definitely more
story to tell with that character
definitely
[Music]